James Franco addresses recent
accusations of sexual misconduct in my
life I pride myself on taking
responsibility for things that I've done
the disaster artist star appeared as a
guest on Tuesday night's Late Show with
Stephen Colbert Franco opened up about
backlash she received from several women
who accused him of inappropriate
behavior following his win during
Sunday's Golden Globe Awards the way I
live my life I can't live if there's
restitution to be made I will I will
make it so if I've done something wrong
I will fix it I have to the things that
I heard that weren't on Twitter are not
accurate but I completely support people
coming out and being able to have a
voice because they didn't have a voice
for so long so I don't want to I don't
want to you know shut them down in any
way it's it's I think a good thing and I
support it Franco is referring to the
times up movement and initiative he's
supported by wearing a pin to the Golden
Globes
I think the point of this whole thing is
that we listen there were you know in
incredible people talking that night
they had a lot to say and I'm here to
listen and learn and change my
perspective where where it's off and I'm
completely willing and I want to
[Music]